horror massencrash auf der a14 richtung
dresden drei tote und 18 teilweise
schwer verletzte zwei autos und zwei
transporter prallten ineinander
meine ganze jugend fußballmannschaft
musste ins krankenhaus gebracht werden
denn in einem kleinbus sei es die b
junioren mannschaft des fc fortuna markt
die jugendlichen waren auf dem weg zu
einem auswärtsspiel nach merseburg alle
spieler und trainer mussten ins
krankenhaus gebracht werden passiert es
dieser crash zwischen den
anschlussstellen halle trotha und halle
tornau die polizei geht derzeit davon
aus dass ein auffahrunfall ursache für
diesen massencrash war
horror unfall auf der a14 bei einem
verhängnisvollen massencrash bei halle
in sachsen anhalt sind drei menschen ums
leben gekommen 18 wurden bei dem unfall
schwer verletzt zwei pkw und zwei
transporter krachten ineinander
mehrere insassen wurden in ihren
fahrzeugen eingeklemmt
unter den verletzten die komplette
fußballmannschaft des fc fortuna
magdeburg in einem kleinbus waren die
nachwuchsfußballer gerade auf dem weg zu
einem auswärtsspiel nach merseburg als
es passierte
zwischen den anschlussstellen halle
trotha und halle tornau ereignete sich
der verhängnisvolle crash mehrere
fahrzeuge rasen ineinander
ein wagen kracht in die böschung von ihm
sind später nur noch reste zu erkennen
ein großaufgebot von polizei feuerwehr
und rettungskräften sowie mehrere
rettungshubschrauber sind vor ort die a
14 wird über stunden voll gesperrt
die gesamte fußball mannschaft des fc
fortuna magdeburg kommt in umliegende
krankenhäuser
kurz darauf postet der verein auf
facebook unter den toten sind keine
spieler des sv fortuna magdeburg
erleichterung aber auch mitgefühl für
die toten hier zu dem furchtbaren unfall
auf der a14 bei halle gekommen ist wird
zurzeit ermittelt
[Musik]
nach ersten erkenntnissen könnte ein
auffahrunfall die ursache gewesen sein
für die verhängnisvolle
massenkarambolage auf der a 14
[Musik]